so at the end of this you're gonna break
me five stars right time for another
black mirror the start of season three
nosedive this my experience with this
this this one was hard to watch although
for different reasons as it went along
now when it when it started and I got a
handle on the setup and what was going
on it made me very uncomfortable for
reasons that should not be that hard to
figure out I mean I I have a YouTube
channel obviously I care about my social
media footprint my social media
impression and to see it's almost kind
of weaponized like that and to see it so
all-encompassing and and and it the
level of it watching that just it just
kind of sank in overtime because
initially I'm watching it okay I'm
seeing her go to this coffee shop and
there's all these people around and
everyone's glued to their phone I'm like
oh that that's already give it and then
the thing there is the camera didn't
even linger on it but every single
person except the clerk who's actively
doing work staring at their phone so
right off the bat with that I was a
little like because I mean I'm not I'm
not gonna lie I've it's hard for me to
unplug sometimes and and I really have
to be deliberate about it every now and
then so that already kind of made me go
and then seeing so much value and put on
basically an aggregation of your social
media footprint that um that's
terrifying because I know at various
points in my life I felt you know what
she felt you know if I could just get a
few more likes a few higher rate
a few more subscribers in my case and I
think it and there were what really made
this work is is it because it's the kind
of cautionary tale about the sort of
thing that could really overstep and
really fall into parody and be like
friggin reefer madness and just be
completely over the top and read like a
sci-fi version of an after-school
special but it doesn't because it gets
the details right and again it's details
that it doesn't even necessarily linger
on
so like when she know she's getting all
these five stars from people and she
gets that four star now I'm talking
earlier on later on she's aiming for
that specific number she's got a
specific goal but early on she's just
she's maintaining he had a good level
she's fine and she's gotten like we've
watched her get like ten fifteen however
many five stars so far that morning and
one four star she just kind of lingers
on that and that rang really true
because I think anyone who puts
themselves out there online and any sort
of artistic sense you know you can have
a hundred people tell you that they like
your stuff and that they they think what
you're doing is good and they enjoy it
and you get that one person who says nah
this is crap and there's something in
your brain that gives more weight to
that one negative piece of feedback then
you know innumerably more pieces of
positive feedback and again they capture
that really well in that moment so
getting the little details like that and
having them ring emotionally true that
that went a long way to making this work
where it could have it could have gone
off the cliff really early on and sort
of seeing the the literalization of
basically social media just becoming
your social life even to the point of
you know the the advertisements targeted
at you because you know you log into
Facebook on a million other things and
they're running ads based off your
browser history based off what you've
been looking at on Amazon or wherever
else and here it just goes up the next
step you look at this billboard and you
literally see yourself projected into
this image enjoying the thing that they
want you to buy and it's not it's not
that far-fetched I mean you know the
technology of actually having something
in your eye all time we're probably a
long ways off from that but certainly
the mentality behind it not far-fetched
at all and that that all worked really
well and made it very uncomfortable
viewing very early on and uncomfortable
in the way that I like black mirror to
make me feel uncomfortable because it
makes me it actually there are times
that this show does actually feel like
it's holding up a mirror and I it can
make you confront things about society
about yourself that maybe you don't want
to and the front end of this episode
definitely did that for me I don't think
the back end is as strong and I think it
ran into the problem a lot of these
sorts of stories tell which is that so
much of the power is in the setup and
the way the society works that when you
actually try and bolt a narrative on to
that it oddly is not as affecting like I
remember reading a brave new world when
I was in high school and I was
enraptured in a terrifying way by the
world by the society by this dystopia
that I was reading about but after about
the first third of it or so when the
plot properly kicked in I started to
zone now and I had a really hard time
getting
the rest of the book because the the
world told me so much more that I found
deep and engaging then the characters or
the actual narrative did and this isn't
quite to that level but I do think it's
just the function of it of this society
and how this technology has caused
people to live day to day the way that
we as people now tend to exist in our
facebook profiles in our Instagram feeds
always appearing to be happy always
being friendly like people so that they
like you back and having that project
out into day to day life that in and of
itself is incredibly engaging compelling
and I just don't I just don't think that
the story is as strong as the actual
environment and setup is and I mean I I
don't want to say that like here's what
the story should have been because I'm
actually not sure what it should have
been instead I will say though that as
the story went on it made for
uncomfortable viewing in a different way
and this is something that might be
that's probably more specific to me and
sort of my hang-ups and things that I
like or dislike I have a very strong
distaste for humiliation in film and
television I don't I don't enjoy
watching anybody be humiliated I just I
don't down to my core I don't enjoy it
and I actually had to check myself as I
prepared to talk about that aspect
because I wanted to say I don't enjoy
humiliation humor because 99 times out
of 100 I've run into this watching lousy
comedies I it's actually it's what makes
so many comedies specifically aimed at
women often insufferable to me because a
lot of them tread heavily on humiliation
humor on their lead characters doing
things that are ridiculous and you can
tell like from
minutes before friggin happens how bad
this is gonna be and then you have to
just watch this train wreck happen and I
don't enjoy that at all I will give this
episode credit in that it wasn't trying
to actually have me enjoy it I wasn't I
don't think it was expecting me to
actually laugh and take enjoyment from
her spiral but it did still ring a lot
of the same bells of you know the
contrivance --is of what goes wrong
coupled with you know knowing what being
able to tell well in advance what she
was going to do that was gonna make all
this go to hell and so it's still
treading in the same things again not as
bad as I as what I usually run into it
because it's not expecting to get a lot
out of me for that so that in and of
itself is a big improvement but it
there's stuff there's just something in
me that like at a deep gut level I just
I hate I hate watching humiliation and
I'm not gonna say it has never worked
for me but I'm drawing a blank off the
top of my head and it's a real fine line
to walk with me so that's sort of the
other way in which the the plot once it
got going it didn't lose me but it went
from unsettling me in a way because I
saw myself and aspects of my life and
things that I have done or or make a
point of trying to not do but know that
I'm susceptible to all being reflected
up on the screen to being uncomfortable
because it's just treading in a story
trope that I don't particularly enjoy so
one is a discomfort that is deeply
affecting and lasting and sticks with
you and the other is the kind of
discomfort that you're just kind of
waiting for the moment to end so you can
like move on from it so that's sort of
how the the episode unraveled slightly
for me as it went along I do want to
emphasize
don't consider that to be a fault with
the episode I don't believe that that
makes this a bad episode but you know
these reviews are my my feelings about
all of this so that it that's where it I
end up because of me and my history of
my feelings of my baggage which nobody
is under any obligation to share trust
me you don't want it
so overall though I mean it it is quite
good and I rather liked the note that it
ended on which was an odd one in a lot
of ways and what I wasn't expecting
because I mean everything had just been
spiraling down down down down down down
and so for it to end with her in this
cell across from this guy and this
bizarre oddly endearing bonding roasting
connecting with someone through insults
and venting that was just kind of nice
it was a nice moment to end on and it
was it was a twisted little glimmer of
hope for her as a person if not for her
standing in this society but and even as
I as I say what it was that was going on
it really was the antithesis of the life
that she led because not only is she you
know speaking her mind and saying you
know whatever she wants to say but in
this specific case it's not driving her
away from somebody it's bringing her
closer to him and that that is a nice
reassurance to have because prior to
that I mean the most reassurance we got
was from the truck driver who was all
yeah I just don't I don't care anymore
and you know heck with it and that's not
all that unsure that's not all that
reassuring because you you have to be
able to completely decoupled from the
benefits that you get by playing the
game and most of us can't
that unless circumstances have forced us
to already lose that which is what
happened to her because she lost her
husband and at that point she didn't
have a ton of things left to lose so
that that wasn't really all that much of
a glimmer of hope this ending though
with the word it's not just a matter of
I do whatever you want don't care what
people think but you know with the truck
driver she's a she was a 1.4 or whatever
she clearly doesn't have a lot of
relationships a lot of friendships so
you know she gets to say what she want
but she's paid the price for that and
but this ending has lacy saying what she
wants and not paying a price for that
but building a connection through that
and that was oddly uplifting of a note
for that to end on and so I think in
many ways the the episode started out
really strong because it was unsettling
to me in the way that the best of Black
Mirror usually is and then the note it
ended on I really liked as well because
of the very unconventional way in which
it was kind of reaffirming of being able
to unplug in and maybe that'll be okay
it was just sort of the the middle bit
you know sort of the latter two-thirds
up until that very ending scene it just
I like I said I think a lot of it comes
down to the setup is more engaging to me
than the actual story was because the
story was fairly put I'm just just the
name alone you can you could guess as
soon as the premise was established how
much you know people put their or their
worth of themselves and others into the
star rating system that it's called
nosedive her numbers are gonna tank you
know that's what's gonna happen and then
it's just a matter of watching it play
out so you know the the the story didn't
really grab me and once I understood
how this worked which I understood you
know within the first 20 minutes I had a
pretty complete picture you know
watching the specifics of how it was
gonna go bad for her most of that didn't
add new layers to it there were a few
here and there you know finding out that
you actually lose access to things or
you get special access not just by
people treating you nice but like
businesses give you special access based
off your ratings that was that was an
interesting wrinkle and you know the the
punish the punishment thing that was
interesting is with with things like
that but those were like little snippets
little additional pieces of information
on the society but like said the actual
story just kind of goes exactly how
things gonna go right up until the
ending which I did really like so I I
think I think that's about it I think if
I keep going I'll just keep reiterating
the same things over and over and over
again which I might already have been
doing crap in any case nosedive have you
seen it what did you think about it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it there's all the stuff to
do like support me on patreon and follow
me on Twitter and oh my god having
watched this episode it's weird to plug
all that stuff at the back end
give me five stars so until next time
links for all that stuff's in the
description this council's adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]